selon les derniers chiffres des
autorités locales plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont déjà été
transférées au total entre 500 mille
sept cent mille réfugiés pourraient être
évacuées notre correspondante en russie
maëlys d'esprit s'est rendu dans un
hôtel de la région de rostov à la
rencontre de ces exilés venus du donbass
nous voici dans un hôtel de rostov sur
le don ou les réfugiés du de basses
peuvent s'installer gratuitement
ils peuvent également recevoir ici les
dix mille roubles soit les 115 euros
environ auxquels chaque réfugié d'une
base a droit pour ses dépenses
essentielles
vous êtes venu seul nom avec ma mère et
mes enfants est ce que quelqu'un est
resté personne n'est parti que pensez
vous de ce qui est en train de se passer
avec vous peur là bas ça fait peur oui
d'autant qu'ici on a tout
c'est la deuxième fois que vous venez en
russie oui on est venu en 2014 pas ici
dans une autre vie et nous vous y avez
passé combien de temps
vous peignez maintenant viol en 2014 et
ensuite quand on est revenu en france
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que cela
arrive à vos enfants le voudriez vous
non moi non plus
ni pour mes petits enfants mais vous ne
savez pas comment ils se font arracher
la tête sous les yeux de leurs parents
moon on l'a connu des parents qui cache
à trois enfants dans la salle de bain et
tous les trois se sont fait trucider ça
vous ne le savez pas
combien de temps allez-vous rester ici
selon vous on verra comme il lui plaira
à dieu on ne peut rien dire pour
l'instant
que pensez vous de la situation actuelle
moi je vous le dirai honnêtement je suis
tellement loin de la politique que je
n'en pense rien en tout cas je veux
vivre tout simplement c'est tout
les émotions sont fortes on entend les
enfants crier les gens attendent depuis
longtemps mais en même temps ils font
preuve de beaucoup de patience ils
attendent tranquillement car ils savent
qu'il y aura de la place pour loger tout
le monde et que on n'effacera pas